[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le prélude au référendum en algérie ce
fut l'arrivée à mers-el-kébir d'une
escadre parti de toulon précautions pour
cet énorme partie qui allait se jouer
service d'ordre pour un cas spécial dans
un rang le calme régnait calme plat
seulement traversé deux patrouilles mais
dont le sens profond se manifester chez
les européens par le refus
oran comme alger votre haine non
[Musique]
dans alger la casbah rester calmes mais
si les éléments de français refusait le
oui les musulmans observait une réserve
absolu suite des consignes d'abstention
du fln peut-être la population arabe ne
bougea pas de ses ruelles pour aller
voter
tout au plus deux rares électeurs pas
certes ils les portes des bureaux de
vote
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans le bled moins soumis aux manoeuvres
aux menaces du fln l'ambiance était tout
à fait différent dans ce village de
kabylie la participation musulmane même
féminine ce nom très compact et il faut
constater que les campagnes algérienne
vos terres et qu'elle vote r oui
[Musique]
dans le bled oranais même influence les
consignes du fln n'ont pas produit ici
l'effet obtenu dans les villes puisque
le bled à voter avec moins de 40%
d'abstentions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
en france le corps électoral a fait son
devoir - largement sans doute qu au
dernier référendum mais plus massivement
que ne le prévoyaient les augures et
derrière les visages des leaders des oui
et des non paul reynaud
jacques duclos
jacques soustelle
[Musique]
guy mollet les français ont apporté leur
bulletin
tout comme eux à colombey les deux
églises le président de la république
est allé lui aussi glissé son bulletin
dans l'urne avec les 185 autres
électeurs de son village détail à
colombes et il y a un nom
[Musique]
toute la nuit le ministère de
l'intérieur a publié les résultats de la
journée dont la leçon devait être tirée
pour les journalistes par le ministre de
l'information monsieur terrenoire en
métropole plus de 75% des votants en
algérie 68 % des votants avaient dit oui
le oui franc et massif demandé par le
général de gaulle pour construire
l'avenir
[Musique]
n'est peut-être pas trop tard pour
parler encore d'elle elle je veux dire
la nuit du nouvel an la voici à londres
d'un trafalgar square et l'on ne
prétendra plus que la vieille angleterre
est un pays rigoriste août folie est
inconnu et toute licence interdite
alors nous voici rassurés essai anglais
quand il le faut savent se mouiller
m
acquise par la force voici bientôt deux
ans l'analyse de la chine sur le tibet
se manifestent chaque jour par une
réorganisation générale destinée à
balayer de fond en comble l'ancien
système la réforme agraire en est la
principale c'est ainsi que les paysans
de la province de notes chaudes et mika
ont été conviés à une remise de titres
de propriété des terres confisquées à
ceux de leurs processeurs qui ont
défendu l'ancien régime
cette réforme a fait aujourd'hui deux
millions huit cent mille me soit près de
deux cent mille hectares de terres et
l'on peut très bien ne pas être d'accord
sur les procédés et les méthodes
il est difficile de considérer sans une
certaine émotion le plaisir de ces
pauvres gens à se sentir devenu
propriétaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
depuis trois semaines la belgique vit
des heures trou liège qui est avec
bruxelles le plus important foyer de
l'agitation a vu se dérouler les
manifestations tantôt calmes comme celle
ci tantôt violente comme celle qui
devait faire 75 blessés dont l'un devait
succomber nonce la capitale du borinage
a été également le théâtre de scènes
dramatiques qui ont eu lieu au cours de
la démonstration de 15000 grévistes du
pays noir
bruxelles aussi a connu des scènes de
violence dans les rues aux magasins
fermés les manifestants au nombre de
quinze à vingt mille se sont heurtés à
un service d'ordre sévère charge de
cavaliers sabre au clair accrochages
sans douceur
les manifestants ont été refoulés mais
on a là aussi compter quelques blessés
la grève coûte au pays un milliard de
francs belges par jour
quelle en sera l'issue
édifié sur les quais de la seine à paris
où elle a été inaugurée par le ministre
des travaux publics monsieur robert
buron la nouvelle maison de la
batellerie s'inscrit résolument dans la
ligne nouvelle
[Musique]
et
vaste parallélépipède sur pilotis cet
édifice en partie financé par la caisse
nationale de sécurité sociale offrira
aux bateliers tous les services avec
lesquels il se trouve habituellement en
contact services médico sociaux ou
scolaires aussi bien que services
professionnels postaux et d'affrètement
le tout à portée de la main
c'est dans la ligne nouvelle que ce
inscrits également cette construction
qui a vu le jour à wuppertal en
allemagne et qui réservé à l'usagé
exclusif des automobiles
il s'agit de deux voix superposées en
spirale le nom tente l'autre descendante
qui permettent d'accéder aux étages d'un
grand magasin où un parking est prévu
on peut évidemment se dire qu'un
ascenseur aurait pu faire la faire mais
on peut se dire aussi qu'après avoir
conduit madama les tâches qui
l'intéressent monsieur peut toujours
tuer le temps en continuant à tourner en
rond comme dans une vis sans fin
[Musique]
sur le ring du palais des sports un
boxeur noir un boxer blanc un champion
du monde avait moore le boxeur noir un
champion d'europe qui voudrait bien
devenir champion du monde des poids
plume gras sur un parti le boxeur plan
de poids plus donner du vague à l'âme
mauvais départ pour gracieux dans partie
qui reste au tapis pour huit secondes on
de ne pas très cher de ses chances dans
les fauteuils de rim
c'est mal connaître le boxeur français
qui va opérer un redressement forte
qu'inattendue
bien sûr ils encaissent encore des coups
mais il martèle lui aussi son adversaire
sous tous les angles à la cadence d'une
mitrailleuse
ça doit faire mal tout cela à preuve
c'est le champion du monde qui perd
toute dignité
qui l'eût cru au début du combat un
combat qui reprend de plus belle après
rapide au bout duquel en fin de compte
tous les spectateurs attendent
maintenant le miracle et pourquoi pas
après tout au coup de gong final pas de
miracle certes mais la quasi certitude
que grâce l empire type devenir champion
du monde
davet moore lui même qui a gagné de
justesse aux points en est persuadé fini
les tribunes du stade remplacé par la
façade austère d'une clinique fini les
congratulations dans les vestiaires
après la victoire l'horizon de juste
fontaine l'avant centre de l'équipe de
france de football
ce sont désormais les quatre murs blancs
de la chambre d'hôpital il rejouera au
football mais campe dans huit mois
disent les médecins
en attendant la jambe gauche qui a déjà
marqué tant de bus ankylose dans le
plâtre
match de la vérité pour l'équipe de
france de rugby maillot blanc qu'une
blanche devant les échos c'est une
vérité qui n'est peut-être pas bonne à
dire cette offensive de l'équipe de
france de 30 personnes tout cela est
désordonné mal conçu et pour tout dire
inquiétant pour l'avenir
bien sûr il ya les coups de pied d' al
balah des gens qui font mouche mais on
ne joue pas au rugby qu'avec ses pieds
les écossais en font la démonstration
voici comment on cartonne un adversaire
selon les plus pure tradition
il faut que tout le monde y passe
trop étriqué cette attaque française les
trois quarts sont encore les uns sur les
autres c'est presque injuste il suffit
encore d'un simple coup de pied d' al
balah des gens pour ajouter trois points
de plus au tableau d'affichage
c'est au moment où personne ne croit
plus que les attaquants français
commence à s'amuser un peu encore
faut-il qu'il soit aidé par leur
troisième ligne la balle vole de mains
en mains mais c'est finalement crauste
le troisième ligne aile qui donne
laissait assez droites la transformation
d'alvalade et joue les français gagnent
par 11 à 0
c'est beaucoup trop cher pour les
écossais
[Musique]